everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm until they're going to be
looking at the Kings Indian defense what
starts out with pawn to d4 Knight f6
pawn c4 pawn g6 and a lot of people
refer to this as the Kings Indian
defense but most of the variations
except for one which we'll get on to at
the very end are actually going to have
the same moves here and so we're going
to refer to this right here as the Kings
Indian defense we can actually go a step
farther with pawn to d6 here as you can
see this is what a lot of other people
refer to as the Kings Indian defense and
what you can see here is black is really
looking to have a very solid King side
defense he's going to castle on the
Kings side and he's very strong but you
can see none of his pieces or pawns had
moved past the sixth ring and because of
this this is a very passive defense for
black what he looks to do is control the
center with his minor pieces and then
later on once he has a strong defense
around his King then he's going to try
for counter play with his pawn start
pushing the pawns up either with e 2 e 5
a lot of times you may see pawn to c5 or
pawn to b5 but we'll get into that
depending on the variation what I do
want to let you know is if you're a very
aggressive player you don't want to play
this as black because pretty much
throughout the entire game as we'll look
at different variations we're basically
responding to what white does so there's
not a lot of times that we can push the
action and be in the driver's seat most
of the time we're responding to what
white does now we all have a lot of
options depending on what white plays
but more or less depending on what white
does we have to respond to not respond
to that and not the other way around so
just want to let you know that this is a
very very good defense and it has a very
strong
win and tie rate for black but I do want
to let you know it's not very aggressive
so we'll go ahead and start getting into
some of the variations that you may see
in the Kings Indian defense let's go and
take a look at the first variation and
you'll see this a lot from players from
white to tend to favor their bishops
they really want to get their bishops
involved so they bring them out early
and this is the Albert Bach variation it
starts out with Bishop to e2 very
logical move this is a very important
piece for white and since you can't
bring it to c4 which a lot of players
like to do to attack the f7 Square
because it spawns here a lot of times
you'll see them bring it to e2 and so
from here like in most of the variations
we're going to castle on the King side
we have a very solid fence around our
King here and then a lot of times we're
just going to respond to what white does
and in this variation White's going to
bring his Bishop to g5 again this is
someone that really likes to play with
his bishops very early on the game he
likes to get them involved early and
puts a lot of pressure on black now from
here black has a few options but more or
less black would really like to
counter-attack on the Queen side and
this happens a lot in the Kings Indian
defense he builds up a very strong
defense against around his King and then
he wants to push on the Queen side so a
lot of times from here you'll see black
push with c5 and this is going to put a
lot of pressure on white but white
really doesn't want to give up the
control that he has on this center so
more times than not you're going to see
white continue to push forward with pawn
to d5 now if he wants to exchange that's
completely fine with us
that's what we want him to do we want to
since we have a strong defense around
our King we want him to start giving up
control of the center but if you're
playing someone who's very familiar with
Kings in the offense from white and if
you're playing it yourself more or less
you just want to bring your pawn to d5
it really allows you to still have
central control but at the same time not
give up any counter play from black so
from here we're going to get our knight
involved and it's very important to know
where you want to bring your knight
we're going to bring our knight to a6 so
that we can bring our knight to c7 and
then we can start to push pawns in our
pieces forward so that we can try to
counter-attack on this b5 square but
also keep in mind if we bring our Knight
to d7 here then bringing it to b6
this really isn't going to do much force
we can no longer push our pawn forward
our Bishop here really can't get into
the action on the Queen side it's really
blocking off our pawn advancement so
just keep in mind when you are playing
especially in this variation that you
know exactly where you're putting your
knight so in this case we're going to
bring our knight to a6
and then next logical move from white is
to develop his knight to f3 nice
development move at the same time
getting ready to castle on the King side
for King side safety and now we're going
to bring our knight to c7 as we talked
about and then we have a few different
moves we can first bring our pawn to a6
to put a little bit more defense on this
pawn that's coming up to b5 then we can
also bring our rook to b8
putting also a lot more pressure on the
b5 pawn once we push forward so this is
the upper back variation so let's go and
look at a few more variations that you
will see in the King's in the end of it
the next variation that we are going to
look at is the classical defense that
you may see quite often instead of a
player bringing his bishops into the
action he's first going to bring his
Knights into the action with Knight to
f3 this is a very logical move
especially for someone as white it's not
too familiar with the kings in the in
defense and it just logically developing
his pieces so first move is Knight to f3
and black again is going to castle on
the King side and now white is going to
now bring his Bishop to e2 he's not
getting quite all of his pieces involved
as far as his bishops but he doesn't
want to bring his Bishop out his light
square bishop so that he can castle on
the Kings side from here we're going to
start to push up with our pawn we're
going to bring our pawn to e5 we're
going to start to attack the center
control that White has here and from
here White's going to castle on the King
side
and then black now is you can look this
is a little bit very different variation
that we talked about before but since we
have our pawn on e5 instead of our pawn
on c5 we can now bring our pump our
excuse me our knight to c6 and now we're
really trying to attack the center
control before in the last variation we
were completely looking at the Queen
side but in this variation we're
actually looking on the central control
before we start to counter-attack
anywhere and so that's why in this case
you want to bring your knight to c6 so
we can add more pressure add to Fitz to
this ephod pawn at the same time
attacking this d4 pawn so this is the
classical variation that you will see a
lot of times from here White's going to
attack the Queen side and a lot of times
from here black may transfer his knight
he may bring his knight to e7 and then
he may start to attack on the King side
it really depends on what white does if
he tries to bring his pawn down to d5
then from here we're going to bring our
knight down to e7 then we're going to
start to a counter attack on the King
side so just very important to know
where your Knights are and where they're
going to go so if you retreat you don't
want to retreat back to b8 and you don't
want to retreat back to a5 once you
comes down to d5 then you want to start
looking at the King side attack so very
important to note that so that's the
classical variation let's look at a few
next variation is the Samus variation
and it's pawn to f3 as you can see here
this is a very aggressive opening from
white and what you can usually tell from
this is White's looking to castle on the
Queen side and we of course our next
move is castle on the King side anytime
both sides are going to castle on
opposite sides it's usually a race to
the king so we're going to be completely
focused on attacking on the Queen side
and more or less he's going to be
attacking on the Kings side so what this
means is it's going to be a very sharp
and aggressive play from both sides so
once you see this you definitely want to
build up obviously you're going to
castle on the King side you want to have
very strong defenses here and then get
ready to aim
the Queen set over here because he's
really going to look to castle on the
Queen side and attack you on the King
set so from here there are a lot of
different variations I did want to touch
on one variation that you may not see
very often if the bishop comes to e3
again if he does castle on the Queen
side he's going to look to get his dark
square Bishop and his queen out so a lot
of times you will see this dark square
Bishop come to e3 we're going to bring
our pawn to c5 now this you don't have
to play this but this is a very strong
game it's all it did want to go over it
as you can see here we are going to lose
material but once he takes our pawn and
we retake I'm just going to go ahead and
through the exchange is he going to take
our Queen we take and once he takes our
bishop we're going to bring our knight
to c6 nice development move at the same
time we need to defend this pawn on e7
but you can see here we have control of
this D file and we're putting pressure
on this d4 square which can come down
the road very important to to black at
the same time we have more pieces
developed and at the same time we have a
very very safe King and white does not
have a very safe King he can obviously
look to castle on the Queen side once he
clogs up this D file but the as you can
see from this game but we've given up a
pawn but at the same time we've kind of
made it very aggressive for black so if
you ever do see come across this
variation you want to take it into
aggressive route I definitely recommend
this game it so this is the Samus
variation let's get into looks like we
have time for one more variation I do
want to talk about the V in Quetta
variation because you will see it a lot
in top play and it's all the different
starts with Knight to f3 and both sides
are going to be in keto on the King side
as you can see here I'm just going to go
through the moves then we're going to
bring our pawn to d6 very common but you
can see here both sides have a very
strong defended King side at the same
time White has a very strong central
control with his pawns on d4 and c4 so a
lot of times from here blacks going to
bring his Knight to d7 if he does ever
want to push forward with his pawn to e5
or c5 it's very important
have his night on d7 to help them out
because really black has to play passive
early on and then try to counter these
two pawns that White has here so these
are the variations that you will see and
the Kings Indian defense if you haven't
already please subscribe and I'll see
you guys in the next video thanks for
watching